happy 2021 reject nation swinging back
into action by
swinging in to this tom holland video
who's swinging his emotions all about
with spider-man 3 swinging the pratt
around chris pratt with the rat
tech okay this is stupid okay i heard
about this
and uh cosmic wonder just re-uploaded
the video with no commentary i think but
let's watch it
let's see let's see what tom hall's all
emotional about maybe he'll stop getting
emotional when he fixes the damn
door it's this a plus meme right there
you just memed it it's a full-on meme
okay just get getting warmed up it's
gonna be a good year
also wanted to mention cobra kai
reactions they should be going up this
week hopefully starting tomorrow morning
if i get my editing done in time while i
catch up on all kinds of filming
peter parker the kid wonder spider-man
himself he's an amazing young man
he's a dancer a triple threat a golfer
and hang on hang on
he was asleep i'm so sorry he was a slim
bro
hey dude how you doing dude it's so late
you're in the uk
yeah i'm staying at my parents house and
they're asleep in there
so i can't i have to be quiet
we started shooting spider-man 3 a few
months ago
which has been crazy and really weird
because we're shooting it back in
atlanta
and that's where i did my audition
for spider-man and we're actually
shooting in the stage that i did my
audition
oh it's like a really weird full circle
story of like
walking through the same door i walked
through as an 18 year old kid like
nervous like oh my god i hope i get this
job
and then walking through the door at 24
making the third movie
loving life confident enjoying
everything that's happening to me
so it's been amazing dude it's been
awesome i've been very lucky
i know a lot of people around the world
have had a really hard time um
and that's why it's amazing that we have
people like you i'm looking down here
you've raised thirty two thousand
dollars tonight alone it's amazing dude
that's so cool
so great thank you it's awesome
i'm so i'm so miserable you asked me to
be a part of this i'm really really
really grateful and happy
oh that's great we'll be grateful when
you
fix the damn door and release that
no that's cool that is a nice little
full circle story i can only imagine
what that must feel like especially if
this is the capper trilogy to really
come that full circle that is very
touching even the fact that tom
holland's staying at his parents house
just makes him feel more like peter
parker i think that's what makes him so
relatable for everyone
is that there's parts of the this
british dude who plays peter parker
that feel like no he's kind of like
peter parker in real life yeah the thing
is every time i see him in an interview
or something he's the least like
professional actuary actor in the way he
behaves and carries himself like he
always just looks like he's super
excited to be
wherever he is and is just engaged with
whoever he's with and
it really does seem like this gods smile
down when they chose him to be peter
parker because he has just this
effortless every man
yeah he's adorable you want people he's
in there
adorable guy that tom holland that's
kind of like how tony
stark went to robert downey jr his his
whole journey came full circle too when
it came to shooting on the end game set
um
that's pretty beautiful but what was
really distracting me this whole time
was the shape of chris pratt's zordon
head the entire
super mario brothers those block heads i
come down
it's like when you see his face that up
close and he just looks like
stoned or something the entire time he's
talking with tomahawk
yeah look at him he looks blasted here
yeah yeah i haven't raised a lot of
money
i need to raise some more people need to
forget that i hate gays
or what was the controversy i forgot oh
god
you know i haven't kept track of them
all
i feel like there are the bigger ones
that's what i heard it was
oh chris i haven't kept up to date with
it i i part way through
it started to look to me like one of
those face mapping things for some
reason like
somebody's doing a chris pratt
impression and it has like a thing
molded of his face on top but maybe he
was just very tired
yeah he was just doing like a marathon
fundraiser
he looks like he's having a good time
anyway there's a really sweet video
happy to have started off the new year
with
watching something so endearing let's
hope this year 2021 is much more
positive
guys subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification bell hit that like
button thanks for
thanks to warren for re-uploading this
video keep a lookout for a cobra kite
reaction should be up this week
see you guys soon